[Music]
is there a food that you love
so much this this right here this oh
that you would go
to the vendor yes and
rob them for the food just kidding i
wouldn't do it
because you're hurting the business i
want the business to thrive i want them
to succeed
yeah right that means it might be your
last time to ever eat this right
no no no thank you we're not robbing you
i'll rob the enemy of the vendor
yeah that makes sense that might be a
smarter move yeah but
you're not getting the actual food that
you like well this guy
who decided to rob a roscoe's chicken
and waffles the one that's right down
the street from us and past the dinner
it's right by my house
right by your house now we know where
nick lives
right next to roscoe's and i have a
whole body i used to live nervous
no now we know where joe used to live
there's a kfc right next to it too and a
popeye and a popeyes
there's a lot of chicken in that area
yes oh yeah i wonder why
a lot of competition chicken street yeah
i wonder why there's so much because
they knew i was moving anywhere
clearly only one of them's worth robbing
because this man walked in without a
face mask
first of all he gets kicked out from not
wearing a face mask
all right he leaves comes back now with
the face mask
comes back with a gun oh no give me that
chicken a waffle
quite literally he's like give me a
country boy put all the chicken in the
bag
just the chicken what about the waffles
sounds like a comedy movie you left
without more money he left
without money he just went for the
chicken that's all he's walking
that does sound kind of bomb though i
would be so pissed
if i robbed him and it was toward the
end of the day and it was under the heat
lamp and it wasn't fresh
oh it's got to be that juicy chicken oh
yeah because it sucks
if it's not fresh yeah that's true i've
had dried chicken there before
all right here we go here's some uh some
news footage that was crazy
robert gonzalez was in the kitchen when
the suspect walked in
comes straight towards me with the gun
oh [ __ ] oh now
you got me and uh oh [ __ ] you got it
back to high school with that guy
he didn't take this guy he took action
you went to high school with him and
before he ran out that he walked out the
door he took syrup
if you're gonna rob a place and not get
the syrup
he's all he gets just the chicken we
don't have time for [ __ ] waffles man
it kind of sucks
waffles are only good when they come out
fresh anyway he's like pour the batter
pour the batter in here give me the
batter
you're thinking oh second thought he
went back let me get some [ __ ] syrup
hey cause the chicken with the syrup is
you need the syrup
and the iced tea he's like i don't want
white meat give me the dark meat give me
the dark meat what the [ __ ] is this
the attention to detail she was like but
he had to deserve it hey what a good ad
for roscoe
that's crazy [ __ ] so good yeah you gotta
rob it my guy
you know what though you gotta mix it
with that uh that hot sauce they have oh
and
the honey you gotta mix it together
when's the last time you guys had
rascals
oh it's been a while
i went in may that's pretty recent
that's really they were open
there like a year i haven't been there
like no no like i've only been
twice really you gotta go yeah
let's all let's go but i don't like
their waffles very much they're so
thin but what about have you ever taken
a piece of their chicken where it's
crispy skin
and then the chicken and you make a
little sandwich with the waffle
and you put the honey and then the hot
sauce and they put in mouth and then you
have the
the sweet tea and then you drink the
sunrise oh you get a sunrise
okay now that sounds good but when i
went i had
dry chicken and the waffle was just like
super flat i didn't understand it
i do i do agree with you that to me the
chicken on roscoe's isn't the best i
would say
hop over to popeyes grab some chicken
from popeyes get the waffles from
roscoe's
bam that there you go that that's that
chicken fried chicken i actually like
the waffles more than the chicken
me too the waffle reminds me of a very
luxurious eggo waffle like
eggo wants to be their waffle but can't
quite get it yep that's true
that's very true that's a really funny
ass crime though
no one even the dude was laughing he was
laughing he was explaining what happened
to him i was like i was uh gun was
pointing at me i was
i i threw all the chicken in the bag
that he wasn't even wearing a mask and
he didn't even bother
yeah but but this must have been high as
[ __ ] this part is what got me
i was like oh he was ready when he went
and
years ago not to be empty you know what
he might that
that means you know what yeah yeah i'm
not just using this as a threat
i will use it if you don't give me all
the [ __ ] chicken and the syrup
and the syrup so he didn't walk in with
the water
yeah yeah butter not the butter the
butter you need the butter too
yeah i'm like what you just chicken in
syrup no you need the butter and the
chicken and the syrup and the waffle
he seemed like he was in a rush though
you know so he was like yeah you could
have just got chicken else there's like
five other chicken restaurants there why
the chicken from there
i guess he really likes his rascals or
maybe he just he's just super pissed off
i'm gonna come in with that i'll show
you
yeah yeah give me all your chicken it
seemed like retaliation for the whole
mass thing
right because come on he didn't rob him
as far as like
yeah why did he get the money that's
weird maybe he's like
no this chicken's worth way more do you
okay do you think he ate it as soon as
he left like when do you
like the chicken he sold the chicken he
ain't selling roscoe's chicken
no i think he was eating it on his way
out yeah
he's already this is act of angriness
he's gonna claim this in court
he's like your honor i was hangry
all right you good man have you guys
ever done some stupid ass [ __ ] when
you're hungry
[ __ ] yeah when you're like on a diet
like i'm on a diet and then all of a
sudden randomly i'm at taco bell and i
ordered like four things
i'm like i thought i was on a diet
that's just you blacking out you're all
mad at yourself give me your stuff
i start contemplating life when i'm
hangry dude and i'm like [ __ ] man am i
like
should i be like doing something more
useful like should i go to boot camp and
like fight for this country and [ __ ]
i'm like oh dude i shouldn't make life
decisions while i'm hangry man
cause i start questioning my beliefs and
[ __ ] like damn maybe i should become
like buddhist or something
so we always gotta feed joe because then
he's gonna be off the grid we're never
going to see him i start questioning
life
you question life i'm more like
everybody can catch these hands
if i don't get food right now i don't
care who i piss off
don't be by me when i'm hungry and don't
touch my food some people don't even
let the uh hunger doesn't even affect
them like jill cannot eat for like a day
or two
really yeah are you sure it's not
affecting her at all
no like because i used to think the same
thing and then i got to kill myself
and i'm like oh my god all these years
i've just always been hungry
it wasn't because i was latina
i just always blamed it on me from
[ __ ] latina
no no because uh like so for me like if
i'm hungry
no matter what even if i feel like i'm
like low blood sugar i'm like
i'm going to mcdonald's like i'll i'll
slide my way there somehow
what i'm saying like with her attitude
her attitude might be affected right but
she can still go without forcing
something in her mouth
it's quite mild like she has energy i
will be i will some things go in my
mouth no matter what oh
oh yeah yeah yeah that's the thing
that's the thing that i meant though
because i i would always just be so used
to you know that hunger feeling yeah
that was
i was just so used to it that i thought
that was your child
you're like it was normal to be hungry
all the time
no but even in adulthood when i could
feed myself i was just so always
accustomed to
being hungry but i didn't realize that
until like
i just started eating more and then i'm
like oh
so when i'm pissed off because you're
like oh that's why he keeps feeding me
yeah every relationship i get into they
like to feed me a lot apparently i'm
super nice
so yeah it's funny because then i'll
i'll walk i'll come downstairs casey's
in the kitchen
and i'll just start nagging at about
[ __ ] and he's like are you gonna get a
cookie
give her a cookie dude [ __ ] my go-to
question she's like
[ __ ] hungry you just throw it in her
mouth while she's yelling at are you
trying to make me
have you ever have you ever felt like
you were being force-fed
and they were tr purposely trying to put
when i was a child
that's how trauma with food started well
i was literally force-fed my dad would
hold his hand behind my head like
food in my mouth and then when he my mom
and him divorce i mean her
when my mom and my dad divorced that's a
song my mom
and my dad divorced my mom and my dad oh
yeah
yeah so once they got divorced my mom
wasn't the cook in the in the house
so i stopped eating as much so but yeah
that's that's what would happen were you
a picky eater like why were you being
force-fed
probably ah one of those eat your food
not gonna eat it eat your [ __ ] food
not gonna eat it yeah you'll eat your
[ __ ] food
yeah yeah that's why that's how it
usually starts so then that's why i just
got used to not eating
oh and then i just never knew that
that's the reason why i always had a bad
attitude you were doing intermittent
fasting before it was cool
yeah me too but mine was motivated by
drugs
yeah drugs and then just someone once
told me
you know this [ __ ] ecstasy is gonna
hit you harder if you fast
which is true what's fasting just don't
eat [ __ ] and when you go to the rave
tonight
[ __ ] take this and i was like alright
dude
you know i took this advice from a 15
year old kid
i was 14 at the time but he was a year
wiser than me
and that that [ __ ] [ __ ] hit me so
hard i was like bro
i'm barely gonna eat now yeah it's the
same [ __ ] with alcohol too
you get way drunker [ __ ] up you have
an empty stomach
as our friends we always go we must eat
before we drink
that's why nobody can stay on a diet or
lose weight
at the restaurant and then after party
because we know
we about to get [ __ ] up so you know
what you have to do you have to eat you
have to eat before
then you drink and then you eat while
you're drinking and then you drink some
more and then you eat after and then you
regret it all the nights and then
afterwards you rob a [ __ ] chicken
and then you go there you go but then
you most likely wake up in a
bowl of [ __ ] because you're dying on the
inside
because you're dying on this you need
that you need that soul to bring you
back
you're like everyone's looking like
zombies and [ __ ] like uh
sunday is going into the vietnamese
liquor so well yeah
because you've gotta balance it out it's
just like absorbing it constantly
drink water space it out eat
food that's why jack-in-the-box line is
always long
people yeah because you got to get the
food in your stomach
strategies if you want to drink properly
you have to follow these strategies
understand how to keep that buzz and
maintain it
and yeah to try not to black out
physiology
yes there's a balance to the game that's
what happens when you work
in nightlife for a long time you have to
figure out how to survive your shift
you're not supposed to be drunk at work
yeah sorry it's a party
that's like going into a party as your
work
and then it becomes work so then the
party this goes away yeah what do you do
to party relax and
still no yeah
i don't think people in nightlife were
in the like bartenders or whatnot
like you just aren't always doing
something kind of related and you like
your job you like to drink you like to
eat you like to do that then the
pandemic happened and then you [ __ ]
had to stay home
yeah [ __ ] that's where people had to
just stop but
when [ __ ] opens up again they're going
to feel they're going to do it yeah
because it's
it's what they like to do people are
going to go crazy
we're going to get the craziest spikes
once we open up
somebody said like the roaring 20s are
going to be coming back everybody's
going to want to go out i want to turn
up
it's going to be cancun but the whole
year on the whole states
man that's going to be crazy it's going
to be um
like an outdoor festival imagine all day
long imagine the first
like no mask concert
oh i heard they're doing that in china
already we gotta go china yeah remember
that photo of the water park
after they got out of the lockdown it
was like a sea of people would you feel
comfortable though
being all up in that nope no i wouldn't
go cove it or not i don't like being a
[ __ ] yeah
no i'm good in the water that's
human soup the chlorine kills kova
though so you're fine
oh god don't listen just go out after 10
pm
yeah you're good no don't eat indoors
[Music]
do